hey it's the last prayer of the day the
men of the Ahmadiyya Muslim community in
Birmingham are gathered at their local
lost after prosecutors traced a link
between last week's London terror attack
and their city communities like this one
are in the spotlight once again it's
been a long-standing worry of ours in
terms of the radicalization of young
people not just in Burma but obviously
in major parts of the UK and the only
that the worry that I have is is
obviously about what preachers are
preaching Birmingham has long had a
strained relationship with its many
Muslim inhabitants who largely live in
its eastern districts newspapers dubbed
Britain's second biggest city a hotbed
for Islamists after study found that one
in ten British Islamist terrorists in
the last 20 years had been a Birmingham
resident among them the perpetrator of
last week's Westminster attacks who
stayed in this apartment Nicola banya he
has lived in the city for over 10 years
her own son Rashid was recruited by the
so-called Islamic state at the age of 19
he died in Syria in 2015 they got past
me and I had such a close relationship
with my son if they manage to groom my
son like that and radicalize him under
my nose then it's I really warn other
families to be really really aware of
what the capabilities of them really
Birmingham has a history of extremist
networks 2014 the city was at the center
of the Trojan horse scandal when
Islamists try to take over state schools
but radicalization in schools and
mosques are not the only problem say
experts I think it's very much the
Internet I think the role social media
has things like YouTube Twitter Facebook
I think they have a real big
responsibility back at the ahmadiyya
most the youngest are awarded medals for
sporting and intellectual achievements
after a community event earlier that day
because a lot of early intervention work
needs to be done with use in order to
basically bring them closer to the true
teachings of the religion which
ironically they claim to profuse when
they're going out committing these
attacks events to engage young people
and meaningful activities are held here
every other weekend local leaders say
that's one way they can protect the
community and fight radicalization in
their city of Birmingham